lo que queremos hacer en este vídeo es
evaluar esta serie de aquí esta suma
infinita que dice la suma desde n
igualados hasta infinito de menos 2
entre n 1 por n 2 y esta es la serie que
queremos calcular ahora bien vamos a ver
más o menos qué dice esto para cuando n
vale 2
lo que tenemos es menos 2 entre dos más
uno que es 3 por 2 más 2 que es 4
el siguiente término es cuando n vale 3
y esto es menos 2 entre tres más uno que
es cuatro por tres más dos que es 5 el
siguiente término es menos 2 entre
cuando n vale ahora vamos en 441 es
cinco por cuatro más dos que seis días y
seguimos sumando hasta el infinito
entonces se ve que que estos números se
van haciendo cada vez más pequeños de
hecho lo que vamos agregando es cada vez
más chico así que podemos pensar
a que a lo mejor será un número finito
está esta suma pero pero no se me ocurre
la verdad cuánto es nada más de verlo
así a primera vista así que lo que te
invito es que tú hagas una pausa y que
intentes hacer esta calculadora serie
para ver si sí podemos coincidir después
a lo largo del vídeo cuánto vale esa
serie ahora vas a necesitar una
sugerencia y es recordar cuál es la
descomposición en fracciones parciales
de esta expresión así que te invito a
que hagas la pausa
ahora suponiendo que ya hiciste esta
pausa vamos a trabajar con esto entonces
lo que necesito es expresar esta
expresión de aquí adentro en fracciones
parciales y expresar en fracciones
parciales significa separarlo en dos
fracciones esencialmente una que tenga
denominador n 1 y otra que tenga
denominador n 2 así que vamos a ver cómo
es esto vamos a tener menos dos menos
dos entre y voy a ponerlo con dos
colores n más uno de un color y n 2
de otro color entonces lo que vamos a
hacer es proponer proponer que esto se
escribe como la suma de dos fracciones
una fracción que tiene n 1 en el
denominador y otra fracción que tiene a
n 2 en el denominador por supuesto el
numerador debe ser un polinomio de grado
menor que el denominador así que como
éste tiene grado 1 pues el de arriba
debe tener grado 0 lo mismo pasa con
esta verdad entonces la descomposición
en fracciones parciales es lo que dice y
realmente nos tomamos esta suma porque
el común denominador es justamente este
producto así que si de si empezamos a
desarrollar esto ok si empezamos a
desarrollar esto que es lo que nos da
bueno primero en el primer sumando lo
podemos multiplicar y dividir
por multiplicar por n 2 y dividir
también entre n 2 y que es lo que nos
queda nos queda a entre n 1 y como
multiplicamos por n 2 para no alterar
hay que dividir entre n 2 muy bien lo
mismo vamos a hacerlo con b entonces
tenemos más b entre n 2 n +2 aquí me
faltó cerrar por bueno multiplicamos y
dividimos entre n 1
n 1 y lo que hemos conseguido aquí es
que estas dos estas dos fracciones ya
tengan el mismo denominador así que esto
será muy fácil ya de calcular porque el
denominador ya es común entonces tenemos
que denominadores n 1 por n 2 por n 2
muy bien y ahora desarrollamos esto
verdad cuánto es a por n 2 esto es a por
n y luego a por 2 entonces tenemos a n 2
a y luego la vez tenemos b por n + b por
1 entonces ve por n más b por 1 que es
ve muy bien y entonces lo que vamos a
hacer ahora es agrupar todo lo que tiene
n por ejemplo este de aquí
con este de aquí entonces tenemos a n b
en eso se agrupa como además b que
multiplica a n
y luego juntamos dos a más b vamos a
escribir
y todo esto va / /
/ n 1 n 1 por n
por enemas dos muy bien entonces ahora
bien esto sabemos que tiene que ser
igual porque así así lo empezamos a
hacer esto debe ser igual a esta primera
expresión que tenemos que es menos 2
entre n 1 por n 2 por n 2 más 2 muy bien
entonces tú dirás hoy hay un problema
aquí yo tengo un número x n y aquí otro
número entonces uno podría decir 2 a más
b tiene que ser menos 2 pero cuánto
tiene que ser a más b por n bueno aquí
podemos pensar que tenemos 0 por n y
luego le restamos 2 así que si igualamos
esto tendremos que además b tiene que
ser cero verdad y 2 b tiene que ser
menos nos vamos a escribir esto
tenemos entonces que además ve tendría
que ser cero el coeficiente de n que en
este caso es cero y necesitamos que dos
o más b tiene que ser igual a menos 2
entonces si te das cuenta tenemos un
sistema de dos ecuaciones con dos
incógnitas así que hay que resolverlo y
una forma agradable y sencilla de
resolverlo es que este primer renglón lo
multiplicamos por menos 1 nos queda
menos a menos b es igual a menos 0 que
es 0 y ahora sumamos sumamos y entonces
tenemos 2 a menos a 2 a menos a es a y b
- b se cancelan y esto nos da menos 2
entonces resulta que nuestro coeficiente
a es menos 2 ahora recordemos de esta
expresión
además b tiene que ser cero pero a es
menos 2 que tengo que sumarle a menos 2
para que nos dé 0 pues entonces b tiene
que ser igual a
muy bien entonces ya tenemos los
coeficientes de cómo separar esta
expresión que tenemos en la serie en una
suma de dos fracciones muy bien entonces
lo que vamos a tener es que esta serie
de aquí
esta serie de acá arriba la puede
escribir de la siguiente forma es la
suma
desde que en es dos esta infinita ahora
de esto esto de adentro lo descompusimos
de esta forma
está descompuesto como a / n 1 que es
menos 2 - 2 / n 1 y hay que sumarle b /
n 2 pero ves 2 así que tenemos 2 entre n
+ 2 y esto de aquí adentro es lo que hay
que sumar así que para que te des una
idea de qué es lo que va a pasar con
esto vamos a hacer algunos algunos
ejemplos por ejemplo qué pasa quién es
igual a 2 quien es igual a 2 tenemos
menos 2 entre dos más uno que es 3 y hay
que sumar más 2 entre 2 más 2 que es 4
que esto de aquí es para n igualados
vamos a ver qué pasa para n igual a 3
muy bien para n igual a 3 que tenemos si
es igual a 3 tenemos menos 2 entre tres
más uno que es 4
entre 4 y en este término tenemos más
dos entre tres más dos que es cinco muy
bien entonces quizás en este momento ya
te estás dando cuenta que es lo que está
pasando qué patrón está ocurriendo vamos
a ver qué pasa para n igual a 4 para n
igual a 4 tenemos
- 2 entre 41 que es menos 2 sobre 5
2 / 42 que es 6 muy bien y seguimos así
sumando hasta el infinito de hecho aquí
lo que voy a hacer es no poner hasta
infinito sino voy a ponerlo hasta una n
mayúscula y después aplicamos el límite
cuando n mayúscula tiende a infinito
entonces si si sumamos hasta un límite
digamos este finito vamos a sumar vamos
a sumar vamos a sumar hasta el último
término que que nos va a quedar vamos a
sumar déjenme bajar esto va a ser menos
/ n mayúscula + 1 n mayúscula
1 - perdón sin más + 2 / n mayúscula + 2
y esto corresponde para cuando n
minúscula es n mayúscula muy bien
entonces aquí es en donde viene toda la
esencia de este problema porque si nos
fijamos en este término el dos cuartos
se cancela con el siguiente dos cuartos
qué pasa con el dos quintos de aquí se
cancela con el menos dos quintos de acá
y así va a ocurrir para dos sextos se va
a cancelar con el siguiente menos dos
sextos del siguiente índice digamos y
así sucesivamente hasta cancelar este de
acá verdad que se va a cancelar con uno
anterior
entonces que es lo único que obtuvimos
fíjense muy bien ya simplificamos
muchísimo porque entonces esta suma
tenemos la suma desde n igualados de n
igualados hasta n mayúscula de menos 2
entre n 1 + + 2 entre n +2 todo esto si
lo sumamos desde 2 hasta n mayúscula
esto se simplifica mucho porque entonces
sólo nos queda este término de aquí y
este término de acá muy bien entonces
sólo nos queda menos dos tercios menos
dos tercios
2 / n mayúscula + 2 muy bien pero
recordemos que no queremos calcularlo
hasta un límite
finito si no queremos hacer esta en
entender a infinito entonces lo que
vamos a hacer es calcular el límite
límite cuando n mayúscula tiende a
infinito de esta expresión de arriba que
tenemos la suma desde 2 hasta n
mayúscula de menos 2 entre n 1 + + 2
entre n 2 que este límite pues será
igual al límite de lo que tenemos en la
derecha verdad al límite cuando n tiende
a infinito de menos dos tercios
2 / n 2 entonces
esto no depende de la n mayúscula pero
esto sí y a medida quien se va haciendo
muy muy grande estamos dividiendo entre
números muy grandes así que esto se va
apareciendo cada vez más acero se va
haciendo más y más chico y por lo tanto
este límite es menos dos tercios muy
bien y ya está toda esta suma o esta
serie
la suma infinita en realidad no es otra
cosa más que menos dos tercios muy bien
y de hecho a estas sumas o estas series
en donde los términos se van cancelando
como lo hicimos acá abajo se les llaman
sumas tales sumas telescópicas o series
telescópicas así que se ve que que que
éstas cuando incluso desde aquí
podríamos ver que se iban a ir
cancelando porque éste corresponde a un
término anterior verdad que éste
entonces a estas se les llaman series
telescópicas telescópicas muy bien y
justo tienen las series telescópicas
tienen esa propiedad de que se van
cancelando los términos de forma
recursiva y entonces fue fue un problema
muy bonito muy agradable al menos para
mí fue muy satisfactorio aunque fue un
poco engorroso espero te haya gustado
mucho